this is unbelievable I just talked about
a Google AI research paper that takes
text and creates great videos out of it
I barely finished talking about it and
what do I see I see
this WOW a better version is already out
there the pace of progress in AI
research is so incredibly quick
unbelievable this one has looked at 30
million videos and can create 1
megapixel videos a million pixels for up
to 5 seconds so what can we do with
those 1 million pixels well we can do
six things amazingly well with it dear
fellow scholar this is two minute papers
with Dr car one text to video whether
you want a surfing teddy bear delicious
sushi or muffins or if you're wondering
what a keyboard made for mouses would
look like this works really well and I
love that it even has a hint of
creativity two image to video it can do
absolute Miracles like taking the
legendary Girl With a Pearl Earring and
animated I wonder what it would look
like if we made her smile well let's
find out together look at that so good
and I absolutely loved the variety of
things that this can generate it feels
like absolutely any topic works even
ones again that need a hint of
creativity creativity in a machine how
cool is that what a time to be alive now
three hold on to your papers fellow
scholar for stylized generation this
will be mildly reminiscent of style
transfer but a great deal more powerful
what is style transfer an incredible
Tech technique from the early days of
2minute papers where you could add one
image for style and one for content and
it would fuse the two together it was
fantastic especially that it can also be
done in an illumination guided manner
something that we showcased 700 episodes
ago or over time researchers extended
the idea for doing style transfer to
even simulations that is incredible
but you know what's better getting just
one image for style and a text prompt of
what we would like to see and out comes
the video with that style that is
insanity for instance look at that bear
dancing this is me when I get my hands
on a fresh paper like this loving it and
now four we can also stylize or edit
videos oh yeah look that's me again so
here the input would be a video of yours
plus a prompt that describes the
instructions as to how to recreate the
video just imagine the creative
possibilities it could unlock you can
try to run dance or do anything and ask
it to take your motion and make a teddy
bear or a robot do that and this is
really just some surface level stuff you
can even rebuild yourself from origami
toy brick you name it five cinemagraphs
what are those well you choose a region
in an image and it will be animated
while the rest of the image stays as it
is six in painting in painting means
that we have a little Gap in an image
and we look to fill it with sensible
information this is super difficult here
you see patch match an amazing
handcrafted computer Graphics algorithm
that could do it and it was powered by
pure human Ingenuity but today with the
power of these learning algorithms we
can even do this for video now here is
the not that cool use case you have
somehow lost part of the video and would
like to restore it that also works but
the cool use case is where you have the
full video you just want some part of it
changed and recreated if you want to add
some new ingredients or create a
completely different cake and add the
chocolate sauce to that not a problem
can you find out that this is not the
original video but synthesized by an AI
let me know in the comments below so how
does this Wizardry work well it
generates all these videos at an initial
resolution of 128 by 128 and then
upscales them to 1,000 24 by
1,24 it is like an artist who initially
uses a pencil to create the outlines
first and only then finish the artwork
with the fine brush strokes but wait
there are so many similar techniques out
there dozens at this point is this
really better than them well we can test
that by calling in a bunch of humans
have them look at the text to video
result of this technique versus the
previous techniques of course in a
randomly ordered manner so we don't know
which side is which and if we do that
what do we get oh my goodness fellow
Scholars we get a clean sweep this new
one is preferred by the people for every
single case in aggregate one of the
closer competitors is image and video
something that we talked about here
earlier that was fantastic fastic
incidentally also a paper from
scientists at Google Bravo I will note
comparisons with numbers these look a
little more competitive and a bit less
one-sided now let's pop the hood and
have a look in there oh yes the new
technique also uses multi- diffusion
this reduces the amount of sudden jumps
during the creation of these videos this
is like a special kind of glue that
makes them stick together better that
creates scenes with no awkward jumps and
what I like here is that the new
technique also has fewer moving Parts
than previous methods loving it I
believe this new paper is going to be an
amazing asset for all of us to be able
to unleash our creativity and I can't
wait to see where you fellow scholar are
going to take it once the first public
implementations of this paper appear if
you're looking for inexpensive Cloud
gpus for AI Lambda now offers the best
prices in the world for GPU Cloud
compute no commitments or negotiation
required just sign up and launch an
instance and hold on to your papers
because with the Lambda GPU Cloud you
can now get on demand h100 instances and
they are one of the first Cloud
providers to offer publicly available on
demand h100 X
did I mention they also offer persistent
storage so join researchers at
organizations like apple MIT and ctech
in using Lambda Cloud instances
workstations or servers make sure to go
to Lambda labs.com slapers to sign up
for one of their amazing GPU instances
today